the 2017 david pakman show calendar is
finally available online I've told you
about it the themes in 2015 2016 were
hey treat male this time the theme is it
is a sort of adult coloring book comic
book and it has all original arts from a
david pakman show fan Dan Burke who did
all of the comic strips it works as a
calendar it works as a coloring book and
it works just if you like funny comics
all related to the show or politics it
works in that way as well and you can
now get this in two ways okay and both
of them are available at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 one is if
you want just the calendar you can order
it either autographed by me uh or not
autographed by me your choice that is
option number one option number two is
if you want to get the calendar for free
you can do that with a with a membership
with a yearly membership we will give
you the calendar for free and links to
both options are at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 so in 2015 or i guess
in 2014 we sold a hundred and twenty to
twenty fifteen calendars it was merely a
test the the 2016 calendar my goal was
to sell 200 calendars and we actually
ended up hitting 201 my goal for 2017 is
350 of these calendars this is what we
would call Pat in the business a stretch
goal but I think we can do it because
the audience has really grown
significantly over the last year and
getting 350 of these out in the real
world would be awesome right we're on an
upward trajectory and I don't think it's
too out there to think we can hit 350 so
order as many as you would like these
make great gifts for people who are
progressive but also for people who are
not and at the comic the comic strips
poke fun at Trump and Hillary and the
show and politics and everybody david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 this thing
is awesome and i can't wait to start
sending these out to everybody